et puis nous vous le disions
rassemblements à travers toute la france
en ce samedi près de 300 selon la cgt a
regardé à ces images de l'île défilent
avec la présence du leader de la france
sont soumises jean luc mélenchon
l'occasion d'afficher son ambition
présidentielle
écoutez le il a pris la parole ce matin
alors que ses premiers mais j'ai un voeu
à faire pour la classe ouvrière les
salariés et travailleurs
les gens qui vivent seulement de leur
travail et qu'ils espèrent en vivre
dignement
pour eux et leurs enfants être libérés
de la peur du chômage être libérés de la
peur du licenciement être libérés de la
peur du lendemain
car demain pourrait être beau demain
pourrait être lumineux alors je vous
souhaite que le premier mais 2022
je puisse revenir au pouvoir comme
président de la république
du travail ayant rétabli les 35 heures
ayant rétabli la retraite à 60 ans